jean baptiste à monique est
officiellement le nouveau maire de
villepreux l'homme politique de 28 ans
vainqueur du second tour des municipales
dans la ville a été intronisé par le
conseil municipal d'installation ce
samedi 4 juillet on a beaucoup de
retours positifs on les sent on sent les
ensembles évident projets en attente
évidemment de voir quels seront nos
premières décisions mais on sent je vais
dire un soulagement pour pour les villes
provient de d'ouvrir une nouvelle ère
nouveau chapitre d'ouvrir une nouvelle
page
arrivé troisième lors du second tour le
maire sortant stéphane mirambeau ne
siègera pas dans l'opposition au
contraire de valérie bain qui a réalisé
25 68 % le 28 juin dernier
l'esprit ouvert voilà il ya forcément
des choses qui vont se produire et on
espère y contribuer le plus largement
possible avec nos moyens on est toujours
dans la construction contre l'immobilier
massif mais toujours dans la
construction de projets au service des
villes provient la nouvelle équipe
municipale et ses 33 membres espère
maintenant se mettre au travail
rapidement les grands dossiers en tout
cas les priorités du moment ça va être
de pouvoir gérer dans les meilleures
conditions la rentrée scolaire si on
l'avait dit on a un retard de l'école du
groupe scolaire des ou dumoulin ce qui
va entraîner certaines problématiques
notamment en termes d'effectifs dans les
classes donc on va prendre dès le budget
qui sera voté la semaine prochaine des
décisions importantes
il y aura évidemment un soutien apporté
à la vie associative et aux acteurs
locaux
je pense notamment à la sortie du
confinement et au contexte sanitaire
avec les impacts économiques et sociaux
qui vont arriver devant nous le prochain
conseil municipal sera programmée le
vendredi 10 juillet à 18 heures avec à
l'ordre du jour le budget